so you talked about being in television
and with some of the jobs the hours were
so long that you really didn't have much
of a creative life so you talked about
leaving that world and then going and
doing your own thing with the writing in
your schedule
yeah I was from one extreme to the other
you know in one situation I'm coming
home late at night tired and trying to
write and falling asleep after like
three sentences and then all of a sudden
I have all these hours in the day and
I'm writing you know trying to work on
my process trying to figure out what
exactly what exactly I need to do as a
writer to get the best product out there
so yeah I left you know I I left the TV
industry and I really wasn't sure what
type of a writer I was I I thought I was
like a writer that really needed to
focus on you know creating those rich
characters and developing that and
trying to explore but I started to
realize I actually needed more I was a
writer that needed more organization
like more structure and surgeon learn
more about the structure of screenplays
and in scenes and everything like that
so how was that having so much time cuz
sometimes having too much free time is
actually a curse because you don't
structure it you think oh I can just do
that tomorrow and then it's a week later
right yeah you kind of expand your days
and all the day's kind of seem like one
you know what I would do is I would
actually go to places to write so I
still do this I you know I go to library
and let's prime my favorite spot yeah
but I think yeah there's some there are
some other places that you could go to
you know you can go you know I know that
the I heard the the writer of the sting
actually wrote his screenplay in an
airport just you know the P had the busy
you know people like shuffling back and
forth he he was able to do it I've also
heard of other writers that it's kind of
a little bit more extreme but I heard of
one that actually checks into a hotel
removes all his clothes and gives them
to a friend and just says I got to
finish the screenplay or else I'm gonna
be you know losing money and I'm totally
like by myself without anything you know
at some point the maids gonna come in so
that's that's a little bit more extreme
and uh I don't know that at the library
by the way yeah I'm probably not gonna
try that at the library but who knows I
mean and I heard of one writer who
actually wrote on a boat from from the
u.s. to Asia some sort of boat and he
didn't have any distractions with cell
phone you know cell phones or anything
like that he just needed to some time
and there was a deadline to I'd say like
any sort of deadline for at least for me
really does help but it's got to be like
the right deadline it can't just be any
arbitrary or deadline you know you can't
just say by tomorrow you know by
tomorrow I'm gonna be done yeah the
library is great too because sometimes
you can't really get Wi-Fi that easily
unless you like log on to their systemic
you know agree to their terms and stuff
so sometimes it's nice to just say you
know what I'm not gonna have Wi-Fi in
here right get stuff done sometimes
Wi-Fi is your biggest enemy really yeah
I mean sometimes you can use it to
research but other times you don't want
to want to kind of shy away from it
I actually got rid of my internet so I
have to go to the gym in my complex to
use the internet and it keeps me a
little bit more focused soon yeah and
that was a conscious decision because
you knew it distracted you yeah I was
you know I didn't want to be you know
researching all the time and yeah it
really puts me in the zone and then also
I don't also write only in my place that
you know I go out and stuff so but yeah
yeah I do a lot of writing outside do
people ever stop you and ask you what
you're doing yeah I mean you know people
are curious and you know I give them the
low pitch but so yeah right now I'm
working on a ensemble film it's a high
school drama about bullying and abuse
and there's lots of different characters
and lots of lots of story lines that are
intersect and yeah it's kind of like the
traffic of bullying or the crash of
bullying that issue and it's all set in
one location as a school and yeah that's
what I'm that's what I'm working on
right now
you